hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remember it so you don't have to and
welcome to another installment of old
versus new
[Applause]
[Music]
say what do i do fee and Jerry Lewis
have in common well they both can be
comedic geniuses when they're not being
ungodly annoying but they both had a
movie that seemed to define a good chunk
of their careers and they just so
happened to be the exact same movie the
Nutty Professor both these films in many
ways are considered comedy classics
it's one of the few remakes that's said
to be just as good as the original but
which one is better which one has more
comedy better characters and the better
story well it looks like once again I'm
gonna have to decide because you
mindless Apes can't think for yourselves
this is old versus new the Nutty
Professor
[Music]
now the categories of those are going to
be a little condensing how there's no
action scenes villains and so on so
forth also I'm going to work backwards
I'm going to start with story this time
because in comedies like these the main
characters the main focus so we'll leave
that for the last anyway with all that
said let's start with story
[Music]
now of course the story of the Nutty
Professor is a retelling of the classic
Jekyll and Hyde except here it's played
up from laughs Oh goofy scientist
creates a potion that transforms him
into the exact opposite of what he is so
instead of being awkward and nerdy and
not good-looking he's the suave cool and
attractive swinger named Fullilove
and he also turns into a jerk hurting
others to make himself feel better and
caring about nothing accepting stuff the
new version is pretty much the same
outline except for a few big differences
and I mean being instead of making Eddie
Murphy into just a nerdy scientist they
added a couple hundred pounds to them as
well
adding even more to how socially
unpopular he can be this works a little
better when it comes to why the
professor wants to transform in the
original he's sort of beat up by one of
the students which I gotta admit the
idea alone on that is pretty funny but
here it's played up a little bit more
from Laos in the new one he's heckled by
a comedian played by Dave Chappelle and
even though the jokes made are funny as
well you really feel the heartbreak he's
going through as he's publicly laughed
and humiliated in front of his date turn
around is his back
the only Lubeck slim
circuit milk
even when
I haven't seen something so hard to
watch since Benz i videotaped in so
shaving his pubic hair oh god ah string
cheese
now both versions take advantage of the
split personality in the Lewis version
his personalities are constantly
crossing over making for some awkward
moments which I had to admit are handled
a little better than in the Murphy
version in the Murphy version he starts
to cross over - but don't like right
before he switches back and even then he
tries to make an excuse for it your lip
is swollen
oh my liver oh that happens every time I
what kind of lipstick do you have on
Chanel oh yeah that happens every time I
have Chanel lipstick on my lip
you have to go catch a cab and um I got
to go to drugs don't get some benadryl
uh oh
okay pick ticket you be able to leave it
in the lowest version it's a little
different well that's what I've been
trying to get you to understand actually
I've never had uh what I mean is uh that
is hilarious there's no explanation no
excuse he just bolts that's funny as
hell
in fact I was impressed that just how
unpredictable the Lewis version was it
didn't always follow the traditional
comedic story it actually throws you for
a few loops the Murphy version is a bit
more traditional the geek is in love
with the beautiful woman she finds him
awkwardly charming but some
misunderstanding takes place where she
suddenly hates him
I really hate those misunderstanding
they just slow things down you know he's
gonna get her in the end anyway so why
waste our time in the original though we
get a lot more unexpected stuff for
example when he first takes the potion
you expect him to start looking suave
and good-looking but instead what the
hell how funny is that he actually turns
into a monster first actually making it
look like they're gonna go for the
traditional Jekyll and Hyde story and
then from his point of view we see
everybody staring at him like he's
something they've never seen before
only to find out that by this point he's
transformed into the swinger but he
loved so they weren't looking at him out
of fear they're looking at him because
they were so blown away by his coolness
that's really clever
but sadly a lot of these comedic stunts
don't always add up in a
to the story for example how come he
never goes through that transformation
scene again he just appears as buddy
love from then on
also there's jokes like this that don't
really fit into the tone the film is
trying to create here and dry yourself
that's a cue sort of cartoony joke but
there's never any other jokes like it so
it's sort of out of place there's a
couple jokes like that some of them just
don't fit in as well as you think they
would plus there's just some weird
scenes like this where the girlfriend
would just go out of focus
general acquainted why is her hotness
just breaking the fabric of space and
time you could argue that supposed to be
symbolic but this is a Jerry Lewis movie
not a racer head the Lord knows he
doesn't it look like that woman with the
chipmunk cheeks also I never quite got
the ending to this movie he makes a big
really well put together speech about
being yourself just as he's being
exposed to everybody yet later it looks
like the girlfriend sneaks a couple of
bottles of the formula for herself
is she gonna sell them is you gotta use
them on Lewis again either way doesn't
that sort of go against the moral and
the characters of the story for that
matter they just never ever make this
clear explain with me x pi oh good
that's just a little one
fours more conventional as the new one
is it does keep everything on the same -
he knows what kind of movie is trying to
get across and it keeps it all on the
same level both films are very hidden is
when it comes to their jokes in my
opinion but when they work they really
work but the new one seems to tie them
together a little better and while I
admire the original for taking risks and
trying all sorts of various jokes the
jokes are just all over the place and
don't always have focus tough call but I
am gonna go with the Eddie Murphy
version it's just more focus and knows
what it wants to be point goes to the
new we are thank you very much I'm
fatter flattered
now as far as the main characters are
the supporting cast is the only thing
that can make them funnier and both
these movies had a really funny
supporting cast
[Music]
first let's take a look at the love
interest in the original the professor
falls in love with one of his students
which I have to admit is a TED creepy I
don't know something about a teacher
fantasizing about someone supposedly
half his age is a little unsettling
like remember that countdown of the
Olsen twins counting down to when they
finally turn 18 dude he knew the one
they were troll children why would you
want to block that and actually I used
the word supposedly half his age because
is it me or does it look like she's 30
in fact all of them look like they're in
their 30s are college students they're
both authentic as the high school
students in io2 one oh and have about
just as many black people in the school
to the Murphy version was a tad more
realistic I mean for one they have black
people huh in this one she was a student
but she was a grad student as well as
serving as a teacher so he can sort of
buy that she would be a little bit older
but now the downside to her is that the
character is a little generic not bad or
anything but she just didn't stick out
that much the loose version was a little
bit more interesting she was a
no-nonsense gal who was direct and
always spoke her mind and even though
she hated buddy love there was something
that drew her into him which even she
herself can't explain I kind of like
this because we don't know if it's
buddy's charm that draws her in or the
fact that she sees a little bit of the
professor with him either way it makes
the story much more interesting how
about the bully again in both versions
they're both hilarious but Dave
Chappelle gets a lot more screen time
and is thus allowed to be a lot more fun
plus is it me or is this the best
revenge in the history of revenge's yes
a point where you take a person's
personal defect and flip it around get
even work with me doing it to you rigid
look at Reggie's gums and teeth look
like his mother had affair with mr. ed
ridges mama is so fat a blood type in
rocket room lady gentleman Reggie had
left the building now be honest don't
some of you wish you could do this to
Dave Chappelle
oh don't you leave the Chappelle's Show
thanks I was in his prime I'll tell you
all give us a few seasoned chick damn
comedic genius but I have to admit the
bully from the original is pretty funny
too it's just so strange how it's doing
with AB you as a teacher like this and
it wasn't very nice when you said that
my practice was stupid no I'm like it
meant that I was stupid and assuming
that practice naughty naughty naughty
now what teacher well no you shouldn't
be except for few like realizing you
must realize what you look you do but
his revenge is only reduced to a talking
down to and that's not nearly as funny
Chappelle is obviously the funnier guy
here but for me the most hilarious
character is the dean from the original
I just love how stereotypically white he
is this is the over-the-top Thai dance
who always wants everything to run
smoothly do you happen to recall what
that attitude was a Maiko blisterin the
results were negative and no lazy noisy
we've seen this character a dozen other
times and a lot of other films but the
timing and exaggerated delivery this guy
has just makes him unbelievably funny
the Dean in the other movie is good too
and he certainly has a strong moments
comfy great anything I can get for you
juice coffee rack of lamb but this guy
is just so memorable watch how quickly
he switches moods I saw young Phipps the
other day you recall I know theps was in
my class that day oh yeah that's really
what we have to say said he's feeling
much better and that the bandages should
be off in about two weeks
Oh exactly that's exactly what I mean
you are a menace that was like a
millisecond and that's funny as hell now
some of you might be wondering about the
family in the newer version who's all
played by Eddie Murphy it's not to say
whether or not I should include them
seeing how they're all
same person I don't know I think it
started sheeting to include them
personally but even if I did include
them I would still lean towards the
Lewis version as funny as they are they
seem a little bit more distracting than
they do helping I mean this humorous but
not hilarious I'm just admiring the
effects more than I am the actual comedy
with that said idling towards the Lewis
version because even though they have
fewer characters than the Murphy version
they're still so damn memorable and
don't get me wrong the ones in the
Murphy version are too but these
characters seem to be written a little
tighter and are a little bit more direct
which means you get a lot more comedy
out of them and at a faster pace well I
guess logically that means they do a
better job at participating to the humor
of the film and that gets my vote plank
goes to the lowest version but right
right
[Music]
and now for the big deciding point the
comedic lead which one of these guys was
not only funnier but had a lot more
heart in its character this is the main
lead
[Music]
this is another one that's hard to
choose because both these guys are
hilarious in their own right they can
get a little grading at times but for
the most part they're just gold but we
gotta make a decision here so let's
start with both of them as the professor
both Murphy and Louis do a great job
creating these innocent yet socially
unpopular people Louis focus is more on
the goofiness of the character well just
don't do shopping shit there that is
laughs class dismissed while Murphy
focuses more on the fragile human side
seem to have miss Mississippi I mean I
haven't really miss myself I mean I miss
my shirt but to be fair that's not to
say Louis doesn't at times either
like I said his ending speech I think is
one of the most vulnerable moments ever
put up though and because he doesn't
have to wear a fat suit he's also
allowed to do a lot more fast physical
humor this physical humor in the new
version as well but it's mostly special
effects related now granted Louis's
voice can get pretty annoying at times
now that you ran up the additive was
specifically a three part carbon five
part time to one part nitrogen and three
part oxygen thinking whenever so
cheering Louis's extended family in this
version yes but then again I guess the
professor's voice is supposed to be a
little annoying that was sort of the
idea and it never does shadow the kind
hopelessness that the character
possesses I don't know for me it's kind
of a tie as I feel really sorry for both
of them and yet I also find them both
incredibly funny but let's take a look
at the other persona buddy Locke these
two couldn't be more different
Luce plays him as this smooth swinger
who acts like nothing impresses him I
know what you thinking
where has he been all my life right
Murphy plays him like an eccentric
billionaire who can do whatever you want
and enjoys every second of it take a
break nigga ready take the Everly
Brothers with you come on it's show time
but this is where I really have my
problem
and believe it or not it's not what the
Murphy version is with Louis's I know
what he's trying to do sort of a satire
Dean Martin playing it so cool that he's
able to get away with murders the thing
is though that I buy the part of him
that's supposed to be a jerk but I don't
buy the part about him being suave he
just seems like a rich asshole
there's nothing charming about him at
all which is weird he's a good singer
fancy dresser can defend for himself
even if he does punch like a girl so
what's wrong with I think this comes
from the fact that nothing about him
seems confident it seems like an ass
whenever I look at him I feel like
here's an insecure due she's trying to
look like a not insecure dude and yet
still comes across as an insecure douche
douche one of the thing ah that no way
to talk what'll it be and don't get me
wrong Murphy's version is a douche too
but at least he has a lustful life he
enjoys everything he's the kind of
person you want to go partying you can
understand why people would want to be
around him have you hurt your feelings
or anyone else's feelings the hell I
believe you have a lot of fun through it
I don't get that with Lewis it seems
like a wimp who's trying to act like a
tough guy and that shouldn't be
everything about him is written right
and I love the way he just appears in
the room you ever notice that he never
walks in he just worked up ears but I
just never believed he was a cool jerk
now there's lots of people that can pull
off the cool jerk and still seem
confident like Jack Nicholson Orson
Welles Marlon Brando that bitch from
peanuts but I never got it out of Lewis
Murphy's version while certainly wild
and over-the-top it still seemed likable
even while you was doing horrible things
tough to say because I loved both
versions of the professor so much but I
think Murphy's is just a little bit more
believable and therefore more
identifiable even if he is a wild pain
and like I said I love both of these
movies a lot but if you had to twist my
arm and force me to choose I've had to
go
the newer version mostly because
Murphy's characters just seem more
complete and on top of that the film
just seems more focused true there are
many moments in the old that are funnier
and if it hadn't been for the original
version this one won't even exist but
this just seems like the more complete
film and it gets my vote as the better
movie the Eddie Murphy version the
superior cavity Oh or Cleese our
gleefully and that's my old versus new
on the Nutty Professor movies I hope you
liked the show and the parents of that
peppermint pattie kid cuz I didn't like
what I said about their daughter hello I
can't understand you why don't you stop
blowing the horn and walking talk to me
I wanna stop your grant remember so you
don't have to
Wow
[Music]
Hercules Hercules Hercules